alors je vais vous poser une question
oui allez-y je veux impérativement vous
poser la fin avant la fin de cette
émission
je sais que nous avons des goûts communs
pour un homme et je
fais attention
et je voudrais vous poser une question
on raconte que
vous avez des couilles au cul vraiment
on dit ça on dit c'est pas une bonne
femme c'est aussi une bonne femme qui a
des couilles au dessus est-ce que vous
pouvez nous les montrer ou c'est
seulement dans la terre
Jean-Pierre Coffe je sais qu'on prend
absolument pas de quoi vous parlez après
mais avec un grand c'est un compliment
oui j'espère bien d'une bonne femme
mais vous parliez pas de oui enfin
physiquement non quoi mais